[Música]
la primera vez que me tocó dar un
discurso político me tocó el 2 de mayo
el presidente saliente daba su última
rendición de cuentas
la sala estaba fría
todos vestían de negro
la mayoría de los rostros eran
masculinos
y había un silencio profundo
me toca hablar
tuve que acercarme al podio
y me percato de un detalle nos llega al
micrófono
me tuvieron que acercar un banquito para
que yo pudiera subirme a él y poder
hablar
claro
la política tradicional y probablemente
quien diseñó el podio para la para ese
lugar jamás pensó que una mujer podía
estar a la altura de la presidencia de
la asamblea legislativa
voy a pedirles que hagamos juntos este
ejercicio imaginemos un salón comunal
como de este tamaño
en el centro hay una mesa redonda
ustedes están ahí en conjunto con diez
personas más les dan una tarea tienen
que hacerla en una semana esa tarea va a
cambiar la vida del país en el que
ustedes viven pero no están solos tienen
cerca de dos mil personas rodeando los
algunos los aconsejan las aconsejan
otros les hacen porras muchos los
critican los señalan los juzgan
cuéntenme cómo se sienten en esa mesa
probablemente estresados
con miedo postrados frustradas
bueno les cuento que así se sentían las
y los diputados en la discusión del plan
fiscal
y porque traigo este tema acá
porque no es poco común la afirmación de
la política tiene que cambiar
claro pero que tiene que cambiar
probablemente hay miles de respuestas yo
les quiero compartir una la mía en la
que yo creo
hay que humanizar la política si no nada
va a cambiar
y qué significa eso que implica en
primera instancia tener noción y
conciencia de las emociones que además
les cuento algo son absolutamente
humanas y las compartimos en su mayoría
con los animales voy a mencionar dos
nada más
la primera el miedo el miedo surge
cuando tenemos conciencia de que nuestro
sistema de sobrevivencia nuestra
cotidianidad está en cambio o en riesgo
ya viene que para eso aún no la política
para cambiar los esquemas pero no
nosotros mismos somos presos de ese
miedo del al cambio que generamos y
muchas veces no tenemos la capacidad de
soltar
la otra más común y creo que ustedes la
ven más es el enojo el enojo también es
una emoción que compartimos con los
animales es absolutamente natural y
surge cuando no tenemos la capacidad de
ser visibles para nosotros mismos o para
los demás
yo me atrevería a pensar que fácilmente
más de la mitad de las decisiones que
tomamos en ese lugar y en nuestras vidas
tiene que ver con el enojo
pero esas emociones no son estables
cambian evolucionan
se mueven
pero tenemos que empezar por ser
conscientes de que están ahí
les voy a contar una historia
8 de mayo día de la mujer
estamos en la asamblea legislativa con
46% de mujeres y una compañera diputada
de pensamiento radicalmente distinto al
mío en medio de una actividad de estas
se me acerca y me dicen caro
vieras que no se quede sororidad por si
acaso solo sororidad significa
solidaridad o entre las mujeres que
simbólico que ese día alguien que piensa
diferente me lo pregunten y yo tenía dos
caminos frente a eso el primero es subir
la historia twitter de lo que aquí
estaba pasando probablemente hubieran
ganado fácil 5000 likes
pero
hubiera arruinado parte de su capital
político y por supuesto mi ego se
hubiera hinchado porque me hubiera hecho
muy famoso por contar esa historia y
revelar la situación el otro camino era
el camino de la empatía
y recordé mis herramientas de
comunicación no violenta que aprendido
se las voy a contar
la primera observe lo que pasaba
alguien que no sabía algo se acercó a
preguntarme eso es un momento de oro que
vale porque está mostrando su
vulnerabilidad y me está pidiendo ayuda
2 identifique el sentimiento que estaba
experimentando probablemente se sentía
juzgada preocupada
y tres tenía una clara necesidad
insatisfecha de claridad y de
conocimiento yo tenía el privilegio de
haber tenido acceso a ese conocimiento y
a esa claridad ella no porque no
compartirlo
adivinen qué pasó no me gane ni un solo
like en twitter pero megan el like más
importante el de ella porque después de
eso construimos una relación de
solidaridad
justamente solorio
en muchos otros acuerdos
todos los días me levanto y veo noticias
y claramente como política analizó la
situación de américa latina' los
procesos geopolíticos
y veo países
que tienen que cada vez están más
polarizados que tienen discusiones donde
se burlan de personajes de situaciones
yo realmente creo y por supuesto ponen
en riesgo la economía las finanzas la
educación de ese país y me trae a la
costa rica los 40 y pienso cuando en un
contexto de guerra costa rica tenía la
posibilidad de decidir ese camino o
abolir el ejército como lo hizo y rompe
un paradigma después en los ochentas
muchos países optan por gastar toda su
materia prima talar árboles nosotros
decidimos conservar
ahora en un contexto geopolítico peleado
polarizado complejo tenemos la decisión
de seguir ese camino o empezar a tomar
decisiones desde la colaboración la
solidaridad la empatía esa es mi misión
quienes se apuntan conmigo
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]